τάξιδ είμαι μαζί σας θα σας ώσουμε να αυτά αποχρειαζόχρειάζεστε μας έδωσε το υπουργείον οικονομικών
τες τας εγκί τερής χρια όμαστα και ξεκινησαμε νεμείς νατη διαδικασία να ετοιμάζουμ τον φακελλο
της υποψιβιήτας ολόν αυτόν το διάστημα φτάσαμε ποτε σε σημείο που α νακοντά στον αβάγειο
δηλαδή όλοι αυτή καθυστέρησης στο γύπεδο να θα εμποροήσουμε να θα ξειασιες φτάσαμε κόντα στων
αβάγειο να σου πω μετά που πήραμε την κατά τη διάρκια της υποβολής της υποψηφιοήδας
αλλά και στην παρουσία ση ποπήγαμε δεν είχαμε εν ποι νδήποτε καθυστέρηση ι οποια δήποτε
εμπλοκή πήγαμε μπολύ τεκμηρωμένη αντιθέτως είχαμε πει η ομάδα ότι ξέρεις θα το κάνουμε να
πλά για την εμπυρία τρόγονπρόγοντας όμως ανοίκει περισσότενι ονόρεξη και κάτετ διάρκεια της διαδικασίας δεμ
μπορούμε μπορούμε μπορούμε μπορούμε και στο τέλιος της ημέρας το πετύχαμε περάσαμε να που πάρα
πολλα προβλήματα δεν θα το κρύψω από πολλά εντο να συνεθήματα και απογοείτευσης πρόβληματισμού είναι
πολύ δύσκολον να σε πνήγι το δίκαιος και να μην το βρίσκεις τα λειπορεία άνχος
παραα των τών υπήρξε φορά που είπε κάνει θα το γάμουμε γιατι κουράστικαμε όχι μπορεί
μεταξύ μας ν εξετάζαμε σθενάρια πο σκετί θα κή γίνικε κεταλιβά αλλά επειδή υπαρέα των
τριών ο καθένας ήξερε των δικώ του τομέανευθύνις και τι αναλάμβανεο καθενας βεβαίως όλι ξέρουν
την ομοσπονδίαν και των πρόεδρον της όμως ποντίας οποίς ντάξει τα κούησυνέχειαν και τα θετικά
και τα αρμητικά κύριο στααρνηλιά υπάμε ότι βάλαμε ν έναν πλάνων και ευπαμε ότι θα
το πάρουμε όλο δεγοέι καθόνε την μπορεία σε εμνά τα πεινά χαμηλούς τόνους δεν θα
παντο